[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIQUEZ: So we're going
to continue with our discussion
of the derivative.
So now, let me
recall the definition
we introduced at the end of
last time of the derivative.
So let I be an interval,
meaning it could be open,
closed, it could go
out to plus infinity,
it could go out
to minus infinity.
But you know what
an interval is.
And let's take a function
from that interval to R.
So we say, f is differentiable
at a point c in I.
If this limit of f
of x minus f of c
over x minus c, this difference
quotient, if this limit exists.
If this limit exists, we also
denote it by f prime of c.
And last time, we showed that--
we gave a simple example,
that from last time,
that if x equals alpha
times x to the n,
then this function is
differentiable at every c,
and its derivative is
equal to n times alpha x
c to the n minus 1.
Now, let's state this in an
equivalent way using sequences.
Remember, we had
this characterization
of limits of functions.
And the function we're
looking at is f of x
minus f of c over x minus c.
We had this equivalence between
limits and limits of sequences
from last time, that
the limit as, let's say,
g of x as x goes to c
equals L, if and only
if for every sequence x
sub n converging to c g
if x sub n converges to
L as n goes to infinity.
So we can restate what
it means for a function
to be differentiable at a
point and its derivative
to be L, say, if and only
if for every sequence
x sub n, with x sub n
not equal to c for all n,
and converging to c, we have
that L is equal to this limit
as n goes to infinity of now
this sequence of numbers,
f of xn minus f of c
over x of n minus c.
So today, the theme of
today is the connection
between differentiability
and continuity.
And we have a very
easy implication,
which is that if a function
is differentiable at a point,
then it must be
continuous at that point.
So that's a statement
of this theorem,
if f going from an interval
to R is differential at c,
then f is also continuous at c.
So let me also add in here
that continuity at the point
c in an interval is
equivalent to saying
that the limit as x goes to
c of f of x equals f of c.
Now, this is just a subtle
point that I want to make,
is that for an interval,
open, closed, half open, half
closed, whatever, any
point in that interval
is a cluster point
of that interval.
And therefore, this
definition I made up there
is actually meaningful.
And for continuity, something
being continuous at c
is equivalent to--
if c is a cluster point, which I
just said it is-- it always is,
this limit equals the function
evaluated at the point.
So that's just kind of a
subtle comment I want to make.
So how do we prove this?
We write the limit as x goes to
the c of f of x as in this way.
So essentially, what I do is,
I add and subtract f of c.
And then, the part that
is f of x minus f of c,
I multiply by x
minus c and divide
by x minus c, which
is perfectly fine.
Because remember,
for a limit, I'm
never actually looking at
points where x equals c.
So that's fine.
And so, I get this
expression here.
Now, what we know about limits,
is that the limit of the sum
is the sum of the limits as
long as all these limits exists.
And the limit of the
product is a product
of the limits, again, assuming
all of these limits exists.
And the limit as x goes to
c of everything you see here
do exist.
So as x goes to c, this thing
in brackets, or in the--
I guess these are brackets.
I don't know what
those are called.
This limit here is f prime of c.
As x goes to c of x
minus c, that's just 0.
And f of c is just a constant.
There's nothing changing with x.
So the limit of a
constant is that constant.
So I just get f of c.
So the limit of this
whole expression
is f prime of c times 0 plus
f of c, which equals f of c.
So we've just proven that the
limit as x goes to c of f of x
is equal to f of c, which
is what we wish to prove.
And therefore, a function which
is differentiable at a point
must be continuous
at that point.
So as beginning math students,
we're learning proofs,
but we're also
learning questions,
what types of questions to ask.
And whenever you come
across a new theorem that
has one implication, one
hypothesis, one conclusion,
then you should ask yourself,
does the converse hold?
Does the conclusion also
imply the hypothesis?
So we've shown that
f differentiable at c
implies f is continuous at c.
So does the converse hold?
Namely, if f is
continuous at a point,
does this imply that f is
differentiable at that point?
And as you can see already
there, the answer is, no.
I think you've probably
covered this in calculus.
But what's the function that
gives this counterexample that
is continuous at c but
not differentiable at c?
Well, let's take, for
example, c equals 0.
And let's look at
the function f of x
equals the absolute value of x.
In this function here, this
is continuous at every point.
So in particular, at c equals 0.
But it's not differentiable
at c equals 0.
And how do you come up with--
and how do you do that?
How do you show something's
not differentiable?
The simplest way is to
use this remark up here
by finding a sequence
converging to c,
so that the difference
quotient does not have
a limit as n goes to infinity.
So that's what we'll
do here is, we'll
find a sequence x sub
n, with x sub n not
equal to 0 for all
n converging to 0,
such that this limit
does not exist.
Rather than write that, because
the limit does not exist,
it doesn't make really sense
for me to even write that.
Let me write this as saying,
as the sequence is divergent.
Now, how are we going to come
up with this sequence, x of n,
so that the difference
quotient does not converge?
Well, what's the logic?
So for f of x equals
the absolute value of x,
it looks like this.
It looks like x--
it's equal to x over
here minus x over here.
So if you were to
formally differentiate--
well, I mean, you could actually
differentiate to the left of 0,
you get the derivative
is equal to minus 1.
To the right, the
derivative is 1.
So that kind of
suggests maybe there's
some funny business
going on at 0.
So let's look at
a sequence which
alternates between being
negative and positive,
but it's converging
to 0, and see
if that sequence will
provide us with this desired
sequence which results in
the difference quotient being
divergent.
So let's just take a guess.
Let xn be minus 1
to the n over n.
It doesn't have to be this one,
just something that alternates
back and forth would be enough.
So this could be n
squared here, or 2n,
or n to the 2020,
whatever you like.
Then, this is clearly
always non-zero.
And it converges to 0.
And of course, why
it converges to 0?
I mean, you could prove this
by epsilon m definition,
but also if I take the
absolute value, that's
less than or equal to 1 over n.
And this one we know
converges to 0, 0.
So by squeeze theorem,
the thing in the middle
must converge to 0.
And we're done.
So we have this sequence
x sub n equals minus 1
to the n over n, which is
alternating back and forth.
And we hope it's going to result
in this difference quotient
being divergent as
n goes to infinity.
And so, we compute that.
Let's look at the
difference quotient
f of x sub n minus f of 0.
F of 0, which is 0.
So I just get f
of x sub n, which
is the absolute value of
minus 1 to the n over n
over x sub n, which is
minus 1 to the n over n.
This is just equal to--
so this is just equal
to 1 over n over minus 1
to the n over n, which equals
minus 1 to the minus n.
But minus 1 to the
minus n, this is
equal to the same thing
as minus 1 to the n.
So this sequence here
of difference quotients,
so f of xn minus f
of 0 over xn minus 0,
this is just equal to
the sequence minus 1
to the n, which we
know is divergent,
doesn't have a limit.
That's one of the first
examples of a sequence
we proved does not converge.
So in summary, this
function f of x
equals the absolute value of
x is continuous at c equals 0,
but not differentiable
at c equals 0.
So now, a natural question that
people asked is, so a function
being continuous at a
point does not necessarily
imply that it's differentiable.
But let's take a
function which is
continuous on the
real number line.
Is there a point where
it's differentiable?
So it's already on the board.
But this is not completely
a crazy question to ask.
For example, let's
go back to f of x
equals the absolute value of x.
This function is differentiable
everywhere except 0.
So there's lots of points
where this function is
differentiable.
It's differentiable for c
positive and c negative.
So for this continuous
function, there
does exist points where
it's differentiable.
And you can imagine trying
to draw any kind of curve
that you can on
a piece of paper.
And you can probably
find a point
on that curve that
has a tangent.
I mean, if you sit
there with a pencil
and then try to draw
something very jagged,
I mean, there are
still going to be
little sections of your jagged
curve where it has a tangent.
So I imagine this is
why people thought
this was the case, that
a continuous function has
to have at least one point
where it's differentiable.
And Weierstrass, the godfather
of analysis, said, no.
He came up with a whole class
of examples of functions, which
are continuous on
the real number line,
but are differentiable nowhere.
And this was a really surprising
set of examples and result
to the community.
And to me, it's also one of
the few results in this class
that you really didn't see
in your calculus class.
So we're going to go
through this example.
Although in most
analysis classes,
it's reserved for later.
But I think we can do it now.
And so.
What we're going to prove is--
so we're going to construct a
function which is continuous
everywhere but is
differential nowhere,
so a continuous nowhere
differentiable function.
And I'll even write down
the function for you.
So what's the idea
that Weierstrass had?
It was, let me--
well, I'm not going to write
down the function just yet.
But the idea of the
constructing such a function
is that it should be
highly oscillatory.
Imagine, again,
you're trying to draw
a picture of the graph
of a function that's
nowhere differentiable.
You would sit there and
break your pencil trying
to draw just a highly
oscillating function so
that it never has a tangent.
And that's his idea, is
to build a function which
is highly oscillatory
but too oscillatory so
that it's still
continuous at every point.
So to start with the
construction of this function,
which is continuous but
nowhere differentiable,
we're going to need a few
simple facts to start off with.
So again, let me write out--
state our goal.
We're going to construct a
continuous function from R
to R, which is
nowhere differentiable
Not differentiable, it's
differentiable at no point.
So let's start off with a
few simple facts about--
so I said that we're going
to build a function which
is oscillating quite a lot.
There's two functions you know
that oscillate cosine and sine.
So those are going to
be our building blocks.
We'll choose one of them.
Let's choose cosine, say,
as to be our building block.
But anyway, so let's start
off with some elementary facts
about cosine.
So first is that for all x, y,
and R, cosine x minus cosine y
is less than or equal to the
absolute value of x times
x minus y.
The second is that for
every real number c,
and for all k natural number,
there exist a y in c plus pi
over k, c plus 3 pi
over k, such that--
and let me label
this as theorem one--
such that cosine of kc--
that's funny--
minus cosine of ky
is greater than or equal to 1.
So both of these are
simple facts about cosine.
Really, this one just follows
from the angle sum formula.
This one follows from the
periodicity of cosine.
But so, why are these true?
So first off, we did
prove-- and maybe I
should have used sine instead
of cosine in all of this.
But if you recall from
our continuity section,
we proved that for all x
and y, sine x minus sine y
is less than or equal to
the absolute value of x
minus y for all x and y.
And there was a simple relation
between cosine x and sine
of something.
And that's just a
shift by pi over 2.
Then cosine of x
minus cosine of y,
this is equal to
sine x plus pi over 2
minus sine y plus pi over 2.
And if you like, let me
instead of using x and y here,
let me use a and b.
So then, this is less than
or equal to x plus pi over 2
minus y plus pi over 2
using this inequality.
So that proves number one.
For number two, it's just
a simple fact about cosine
being 2 pi periodic.
So function g of x
equals cosine k of x.
This is also periodic.
But now, what's the period?
It's 2 pi over k.
Now, this interval
has link 2 pi,
except it's missing the
point c plus pi over 2
and c plus 3 pi over k.
Thus, if I look
at the image of--
OK.
Then, so this function g
of x equals cosine k of x.
If I look at the image
of this interval,
this will contain all of the
real numbers between minus 1
and 1.
So this is a period.
This is a interval
of link 2 pi over k.
Cosine kx is 2 pi
over k periodic.
So I should get
everything between minus 1
and one except possibly
the value at the endpoints.
So take away-- and the
value at the endpoints
is minus cosine ck.
Because cosine of k times
c plus pi is equal--
pi over k is equal to
cosine of kc plus pi.
And cosine of
something plus pi is
equal to minus
cosine of that thing.
So the image of the
set by cosine kc
contains everything
between minus 1 and 1,
except for possibly
the endpoint.
This really only happens at if
cosine of k times E equals 1.
So OK.
Then, if cosine of kc is
bigger than or equal to 0,
then we choose y in this
interval c plus pi over kc
plus 3 pi over k.
Let's write it this way.
So if this thing is
bigger than or equal to 0,
then we choose y--
why am I confusing myself?
So this is simple enough.
We choose y in this interval
so that cosine of ky equals
minus 1.
And if cosine kc is
less than 0, then we
choose y so that
cosine of ky equals 1.
So again, here's-- so forget--
just to get an idea.
So I'm quibbling over
a minor point, the fact
that we have to take away
possibly the point where--
possibly the value of cosine kc.
Anyways, that's erase
this for a minute.
And let's imagine that
the range of this guy--
I mean, it's a 2 pi over
k periodic interval.
So this should basically
cover all values
between minus 1 and 1.
So cosine of kc will
either be plus or minus.
So if it's not negative, then I
can find a y in this interval,
since it's 2 pi over k periodic.
So that cosine of
ky equals minus 1.
And since this is not negative
and this is equal to minus 1,
the difference between
these two in absolute value
will be greater
than or equal to 1.
Now, if cosine of
kc is less than 0,
then again, since this
interval contains minus 1 to 1,
it's 2 pi over k periodic, we
choose a y so that cosine of ky
equals 1.
And then, this is negative.
This is 1.
So the difference between
something negative and 1
is greater than or equal to 1.
And that's the proof.
I made a kind of a mess of it.
But this is very easy to
understand if you just
draw a picture really.
So let's continue.
And again, what these two
parts of this theorem say
is that cosine can
be quite oscillatory
if you insert a k here.
Because the difference
between this interval
is actually quite small.
The length of this
interval is 2 pi over k.
If k is very large, that's
a very small interval.
Yet somehow, we
can find two points
which differ by at
least 1 in value
if we plug them
into the function.
But cosine is not
too wild, because it
satisfies this bound.
So these two are
kind of-- they're
going to be the ingredients in
that idea I said at the start,
that we're going to build a
function which oscillates,
which is quite oscillatory,
but it's not too oscillatory
that it's still continuous.
And we're going to build our
function out of cosine kx,
where k is going to be changing.
So I'm going to need one
more very simple fact.
So this one, I won't
mess up too much.
Which is the following.
For all a, b, c, and R, the
absolute value of a plus
b plus c, this is bigger than
or equal to the absolute value
of a, minus the
absolute value of b,
minus the absolute value of c.
And the proof of this is just
to use the triangle inequality
twice.
We have the absolute value of a.
This is equal to a plus
b plus c, minus b plus c.
And this is less than or equal
to, by the triangle inequality,
the absolute value
of a, plus b, plus c,
plus the absolute value
of minus times b plus c.
But that minus goes away
with the absolute value.
And then, I use a triangle
inequality one more time here
to get--
and then if I subtract--
oh, I didn't want to do that.
And so, if I subtract this
side over to the other side
of this inequality, I get
the statement of the theorem.
So now, we're going
to introduce--
call this theorem two--
now let me introduce
the guest of honor.
So first, I have
the following claim.
For all x in R, the
series given by sum from n
equals 0 to infinity--
and instead of n, I'm going
to use k, cosine 160 kx.
So here's our very
oscillatory guy over 4
to the k is
absolutely convergent.
So for each x in R, this
series converges absolutely.
So it spits out a real number.
So I can define a function
in terms of this series.
Let f from R to R be
defined by a prime--
f of x is just the
number that I get when
I stick in x to the series.
Which is meaningful,
because for all x,
this series
converges absolutely.
So this is just a function.
I put in x.
I get out a real number.
Then the claim is, f is
bounded and continuous.
So this is going to
be our function, which
is continuous but
nowhere differentiable.
As you can see, it's
built out of a bunch
of very oscillatory
functions, cosine of 160 kx,
this is just a really
big number here.
And as I said, when we were
talking about this theorem
here, each one of those
pieces is very oscillatory.
On a very small interval, it
oscillates between two values
that differ by at least 1.
And so, all of these
guys are oscillatory.
And they're oscillatory on
smaller and smaller intervals.
And somehow, we're
adding them all up
in a way to get a function
that's oscillatory
on arbitrarily small intervals.
And therefore, it will
not be differentiable.
So the proof of
one is very easy.
We just use the
comparison principle.
Cosine of 160 k times
x over 4 to the k,
this is less than or
equal to-- because cosine
of no matter what you
plug in is bounded by 1.
This is always bounded
by 1 over 4 to the k.
And therefore, by the
comparison principle,
we get that this
series is convergent.
And therefore, the
original series
is absolutely convergent.
So each of these is bounded
by 1 over 4 to the k.
This series converges.
This is a geometric series.
Therefore, by the
comparison principle,
this series converges.
So now, we have this function
defined by this series.
Note, this is not
a power series,
because a power series
involves polynomials in x.
This is cosine of x,
or a number times x.
So let's show it's bounded.
The same proof actually that we
gave here shows it's bounded.
Let x be in R then,
f of x equals--
this is equal to the limit as
n goes to infinity of this sum.
And now, for our absolute
values, this limit pulls out.
Whenever the limit exists, the
limit of the absolute value
equals the absolute
value of the limit.
And this is less than
or equal to the limit
as n goes to infinity of
bringing the [INAUDIBLE]..
So by the triangle inequality,
this is just a finite sum.
So I can bring the
absolute values in.
And I get sum from a equals 0
to m of cosine 160 k, x over 4
to the k, absolute value.
And this is less than
or equal to limit
as n goes to infinity
of sum k equals
0 to m of 4 to the
minus k, again,
because cosine of
anything is bounded by 1.
And this equals 4/3.
This is just a sum from k equals
0 to infinity 4 to the minus k.
So this function is
always bounded by 4/3.
So the function is bounded.
Let's now show it's continuous.
So to show a
function's continuous,
remember, we have that other
characterization of continuity
that a function is
continuous at a point
if and only if for every
sequence converging
to that point f of
xn converges to c.
So before I start writing
all this down, let c be in R,
and let xn be a sequence
converging to c.
So what we want to
show is that limit
as n goes to infinity of f of xn
minus f of c in absolute value
equals 0.
That's the same as
saying the limit
as n goes to infinity of
f of xn equals f of c.
Now, f as a bounded function.
So this sequence, f of xn
minus f of c in absolute
is a bounded sequence.
So it has a lim sup.
And we did an exercise
on the assignment
that the limit of a
sequence equals 0 if
and only if the
lim sup equals 0.
So equivalently, we'll show
that lim sup of f of x sub
n minus f of c equals 0.
This thing always exists
for a bounded sequence.
Which is one of
the reasons which
is what makes lim sup so useful,
is that they do always exist.
So if we show that
this lim sup equals 0,
then this is equivalent to
showing this limit equals 0.
Again, this was
an exercise, where
you can take it as the
lim inf of something
that's non-negative is always
bigger than or equal to 0.
So if we show this is equal to
0, we would have 0 is less than
or equal to the lim inf of
this thing, is less than
or equal to the lim
sup, which equals 0.
And therefore, the lim inf
equals the lim sup equals 0.
So that's another way
of saying that this
is equivalent to this.
So we're going to show this
at the lim sup of f of x
sub n minus f of c equals 0.
But we don't-- so that
might be a little tough.
But what we can show,
and what we will show,
is we'll give ourself
a little room.
We'll show that for
all epsilon positive,
the lim sup of f
of x sub n, minus f
of c, which is a non-negative
number, is less than epsilon.
So this is a fixed number,
non-negative number,
which is always smaller than--
put less than or
equal to there--
which is smaller than
any number that I want.
And therefore, it has to be 0.
And proving thus, lim sup.
So just to recap,
we want to show--
we have a sequence
converging to c.
We want to show that f of
xn converges to f of c.
Another way of stating
that is that this limit
of the absolute value between--
of the difference between
these two converges to 0.
That's again a equivalent
way of stating the limit.
And in another
assignment, we proved
that for a sequence of
non-negative numbers,
or if you like, just for
a sequence of numbers,
it converges to 0 if
and only if the lim sup
of the absolute
value converges to 0.
But this is a sequence
of non-negative numbers,
this absolute value of
f of xn minus f of c.
So this is equivalent to this.
So this thing we want to show
is equivalent to this thing
right below it.
Now, rather than show directly
that this limit lim sup equals
0, we're going to show that
for all epsilon positive
it's less than or equal
to that small number.
And therefore,
proving that it's 0,
because it's a
non-negative number smaller
than every positive number.
So this is our goal,
to show this lim
sup is less than epsilon.
So let epsilon be positive.
We're now going to
prove that that lim
sup is less than epsilon.
So first off, let m0 be
a natural number such
that the sum from k equals
m0 plus 1 to infinity of 4
to the minus k is less
than epsilon over 2.
So this series here, right
this is a convergent series
if I go from k
equals 0 to infinity.
And we have this
Cauchy criterion
for convergent series, which
can be equivalently stated
as for all m0 and natural
number, there exists--
or for all epsilon,
there exist--
so first off, rather
than go through all
that, we can actually
just compute this.
That the left-hand side equals
4 to the minus m0 minus 1,
times sum from L
equals 0 to infinity,
4 to the minus L,
which equals 4/3.
4 to the minus m0 not minus
1, which equals one 1/2,
4 to the minus m0.
So if m0 is chosen very large--
this is 4 to the minus m0.
So this is--
I can write this
as 1/2 over 1/4.
And as long as m0 is
chosen very large,
I can always make
this very small.
That's the left side over there.
So I can always find m0
so that this is the case.
And now, we compute the lim
sup of f of xn minus f of x.
We split this up
into two pieces.
This is equal to lim sup
then of two parts, sum from k
equals 0 to m0 of cosine
of 160 k xn minus--
so each of these is
defined in terms of a sum.
So I'm going to break
the sum up to m0.
And then, everything
past m0, this
is equal to 1 over
4k times cosine 160 k
xn minus cosine 160 kx, plus
sum from k equals 0 to m0
plus 1 to infinity, 1 over 4
k, same thing, absolute value.
And now, we use the triangle
inequality and the fact
that lim sups
preserve inequality.
So the absolute
value of this thing
is less than or equal to the
sum of the absolute values.
And the lim sup
of those sequences
is less than or equal to
the sum of the lim sups.
That was another exercise
from an assignment,
or you did something
similar with the lim int.
So this is less than or
equal to lim sup of--
now I use the
triangle inequality,
sum from k equals 0 to m0, 4
minus k, cosine 160 k x of n
minus cosine 160 k--
oh dear.
So I've been writing x.
I meant to write c.
Sorry about that.
c, c, c, c.
OK.
And then, same thing
in these brackets here.
Now, [INAUDIBLE]
might keep that.
So we have that this lim sup
of f of x sub n minus f of c
is less than or equal to
the lim sup of this guy,
plus the lim sup of this guy.
And now, I'm going to use the
triangle inequality, again,
bringing the absolute values
inside of the sums, which
is perfectly valid, even
for the infinite sum
by the same argument I
used basically over there.
This is less than or
equal to the lim sup
as n goes to infinity of
minus cosine of 160 kc,
and sup plus lim sup of
sum from k equals m0 plus 1
to infinity of, now,
the absolute value
of the same thing.
Now, I applied the triangle
inequality to that.
Now, cosine of anything
is always bounded by 1.
So this is bounded by--
first off, let me come back to
this second one. m0 is fixed.
Remember, this is
not changing within.
It's just fixed.
It depended only on epsilon.
So m0 is fixed.
And this is less than or
equal to lim sup of int.
Now we use what we
know about cosine,
that cosine of something
minus cosine of something else
is bounded by the
difference in the argument.
So this is bounded by
minus 4 to the minus
k times 160 k xn minus
160 kc, plus lim soup
of k equals m0 plus 1 to
infinity, 4 minus k times 2.
As this is bounded by
1, that's bounded by 1.
Now, there's no n left here.
So this is really just
now equal to that.
And we chose m0 so
that this quantity here
is less than epsilon over 2.
So times 2, this is
less than epsilon.
So this is less than or
equal to lim sup, sum from k
equals 0 to m0 of 40 k.
Now, again, this is
just a fixed number.
The lim sup is in n.
This is just a fixed number
times x sub n minus c.
The difference in this is
just equal to 160 k times 4
to the minus k, that's 40 k.
And then, we chose m0 so
that this quantity over here
is less than epsilon.
And now, as n goes to infinity,
x sub n is converging to c.
So this thing here
converges to 0,
equals times 0 plus
epsilon equals epsilon.
So to me, this is
a real first proof
of analysis, where
you're using everything
that you've been exposed
to up to this point
to prove a really deep theorem.
So go through this slowly.
But there's not too much--
the estimates are
not all that tricky
once you have them
in front of you.
So we've shown that
for all epsilon,
this lim sup is less
than or equal to epsilon.
Because remember, we
ended with epsilon here.
But we started off
estimating this lim sup here.
Now we're in a position
to prove the final theorem
that we want to prove.
And this is due to Weierstrass.
The function which
we've been studying,
f of x equals sum from k equals
0 to infinity cosine 160 kx
over 4 to the k is
nowhere differentiable.
So with everything
we've done so far,
so we this function
is continuous.
We've proven that.
So this theorem provides
you with an example
of a function which is
continuous but nowhere
differentiable.
And with what we
have on the board,
namely the key parts
are going to be what's
in that first theorem there.
And with this triangle
inequality we have over here,
we'll be able to prove this.
So in fact, let me give
myself a little space.
And I'm going to state
theorem two from over there,
because I need some space
to right in a minute.
For all a, b, c, the absolute
value of a, plus b, plus c
is bigger than or
equal to a minus
the absolute value of b minus
the absolute value of c.
So let me re-summarize.
Since I've summarized
it already.
What we've done
up to this point,
we've shown that this
function here is well-defined.
Absolutely, the series is
always absolutely convergent.
And therefore, this
function is bounded,
and/or we also proved that
it's bounded and continuous.
That was the previous theorem.
So this function is
bounded and continuous.
And we're going to prove
it's nowhere differentiable.
And again, what's the idea?
The idea is that we've
built it out of functions
which are highly oscillatory
at smaller and smaller scales.
So somehow this
function is highly
oscillatory at every scale.
And if you have a
function which is highly
oscillatory of every
scale, if some of you
have heard of Brownian motion,
which is a function which is--
I mean, which is a path
which is highly oscillatory,
then that function will not
be differentiable anywhere.
So proof, let c be
any real number.
And what we're
going to do, just as
in when we looked at f of x
equals the absolute value of x,
we're going to construct
or find a sequence x sub n,
such that x sub n does not equal
c for all n, xn converges to c.
And the sequence, f of x
of n, minus f of c, over x
sub n minus c, in
fact, is divergent.
But we'll go even
further, is unbounded.
And therefore, the
sequence cannot converge.
And therefore the function
is not differentiable at c.
So we're going to use theorem
one to find the sequence.
By theorem one, namely part two,
for all N, a natural number,
there exists the x
of n, such that what?
x sub n is in this
interval of the form.
So c plus pi over 160 n is
less than x, is less than c
plus plus 3 pi over 160 n.
And cosine of 160 n x of
n minus cosine of 160 nc
is bigger than or equal to 1.
So let me call these
two properties a and b.
So another way of writing
a is, we could have instead
written, by subtracting
c across the board,
that x sub n minus c is
between pi over 160 n and 3 pi
over 160 n.
So by a, for all
n, x sub n does not
equal to c, because their
difference is bounded below
by a positive number.
I mean, their difference
is actually positive,
and it's non-zero.
So-- and by the
squeeze theorem, again,
if you like putting
the c on both sides,
we get that x sub
n converges to c.
So this will be our sequence--
our bad sequence, for which
the difference quotient
is unbounded.
So in fact, let me write
this out a little bit more.
And x sub n minus c,
which is equal to x
sub n minus c, because
this is positive,
is less than 3 pi over 160 n.
And this goes to 0.
Therefore, the absolute value
of xn minus c converges to 0.
And therefore, x sub
n converges to c.
Now, to lessen the
number of times
I have to write cosine 160
k, let fk of x be cosine
160 kx over 4 to the k.
So f of x is equal to the sum
of k equal to 0 of fk of x.
And now, what we're
going to do is,
we're going to
find a lower bound
on the absolute value of f
of xn minus f of c over x sub
n minus c.
So now, find a lower bound on--
if I can find a lower bound
on this absolute value, which
is getting large,
as large as I wish,
then that proves that this
sequence is unbounded,
and I'm done.
So let's look at the absolute
value of f of xn minus f of c.
Let's just write this
in a few different ways.
Or not a few different ways.
But let's split it up as a sum.
So all of these guys are
equal to a sum of f sub k.
So I have the n'th one.
So remember, f sub
k, this is just one
of these building blocks.
Plus sum from k equals 0 to
n minus 1, plus I put x here.
I meant to write c.
And so, I'm going to let a
sub n be this first number,
b sub n be the second
number, including the sum.
And this will be c sub n.
So this is equal to a sub n
plus b sub n plus c sub n.
And now I'm, going to use that
triangle inequality I proved.
Then f of x sub n minus f
of c is greater than-- which
is equal to a sub n
plus c sub n plus c
sub n is bigger than or equal
to a sub n, minus b sub n,
minus c sub n.
Now, a sub n, this
is going to be--
this is just the difference
between these guys.
This is bounded below by 1.
So it's kind of large.
Not 1, but 1 over 4 to the n.
These other guys we'll
prove are very small
compared to the a sub n.
And then, this lower bound--
this upper bound we
have on x sub n minus c
will be the nail in
the coffin, as we say.
So our goal is now to estimate
from below a sub n-- remember,
we're trying to
find a lower bound
for this quantity
over x sub n minus c.
So we need to estimate
these things from below,
or this sum from below.
That means, we need to
estimate this from below,
and then b sub n and
c sub n, since they
have minus signs, from above.
Now, by b, a sub n, which
is equal to 4 to minus n,
cosine 160 nx of n, minus
cosine 160 to the nc.
This is-- remember how
we chose these x sub n's.
This is bounded above by
1, or bounded below by 1.
So this is bigger than or
equal to 4 to the minus n.
So that's a sub n.
Now, let's look at
how big b sub n is.
Now, we want to bound
this from above.
Because when it
hits the minus sign,
this will flip the
inequality, and we'll
have that this would be bounded
from below by something.
So the absolute value of B7,
that's equal to sum from k
equals 0 to n minus 1 of fk of
x of n minus f of c, k of c.
And bringing the
absolute values inside
by the triangle inequality,
this is less than or equal
to sum from k equals
n minus 1 of f
of fk x of n minus fk of c.
And now, so this is
equal to sum from k
equals 0 to n minus 1, 4 to
the minus k, cosine 160 k,
x sub n minus cosine of 160 kc.
And now we use theorem
one, number two--
or number one.
I'm sorry, theorem one part one.
So this is theorem 1, 1.
The difference in
these is bounded
by 160 k times the
difference in those two.
So that's-- and now, these
things we can sum up in closed
form.
Well, actually, x sub
n minus c, we proved
is less than 3 pi over 160 n.
So this is less than a sum
from k equals 0, n minus 140 k.
And this equals 3 pi over 160 n.
Now, sum from k equals
0 to n minus 1 40k,
we used this formula for
summing a geometric sum.
This is equal to--
what was this equal to?
40 to the n minus 1 over 39.
And which is less than--
OK, so take away the one.
This is 1 over 13, four
to the minus n times pi.
And that's less than--
pi is less than 4.
So plus 1.
So let me summarize this.
It is less than or to 1 over
13 fours and minus n plus 1.
Now, for the last
box, this is less--
the absolute value of c sub n.
And absolute value is
less than or equal to--
now, we just kind of
do a brutal estimate.
We bring the absolute
values inside.
So this is equal-- so
just as we had before,
with the b sub n's,
except now we're
summing from k equals
n plus 1 to infinity.
We brought the
absolute values inside.
And then, let's use the
triangle inequality on that.
This is-- remember, fk is
equal to cosine of 160 k
times x over 4 to the k.
So that's no matter
what you plug-in,
that's bounded by
1 over 4 to the k.
And now this we
can actually sum.
This is equal to 4 to the minus
n minus 1, times sum from L
equals 0 to infinity of 4 to the
minus L. What does this equal?
This equals 2 times 4 to the
minus int minus 1 times 4/3
equals 2/3 4 to the minus n.
So, my board work's getting a
little shoddy, but it'll be OK.
I.e.
we've proven that the
absolute value of c sub n
is bounded by 2/3
4 to the minus n.
So combining everything
that we've done.
We've shown that f of
x sub n minus f of c.
Which remember, is bounded
below by a sub n-- remember,
so the first box is bounded
by 4 to the minus n.
So first off, everything,
the a sub n's, b sub n's,
c sub n's, they
have some forward
to the minus n involved.
What happened to
my estimate for b?
Oh, covering it up--
4 to the minus n.
So this is one coming from the
a sub n's, and minus 4 over 13
coming from the b sub n's, minus
2/3 coming from the c sub n's.
And if you do the
arithmetic, this
is 4 to the minus n, 1 over 39.
So f of x sub n
minus c is bounded
from below by 4 to the
minus n times 1 over 39.
Now I just divide by x sub
n minus c, which is bounded
above by 3 pi over 160 n.
And therefore, when I take
reciprocals, I get that.
I get that the
absolute value of f
of x of n minus f of
c over x of n minus c
is bounded from above by 1
over x of n minus C times 4
to the minus n, 1 over 39,
which is bounded below by now
inserting this estimate here.
I get 40 n over--
I think that's 1017 pi.
Yes.
And therefore,
the absolute value
of the difference quotient
is bounded below by 40
to the n over some fixed number.
And this thing on the right-hand
side is unbounded, as in,
I guess, as in varies
because from 1 to infinity.
And therefore,
the absolute value
of this difference
quotient is unbounded,
which finishes the proof.
So we've done some
things, maybe a few things
that you haven't seen
in calculus course.
Definitely haven't
seen this, most likely.
And really, this
is the first result
that involves a lot of math that
we've covered up to this point
to prove a very non-trivial
and deep theorem that
differentiability is
a bit of a miracle.
It's a miracle when it happens.
OK, we'll stop there. .